JEANINE PIRRO, JESSE,
GREG GUTFELD, AND THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
PRESIDENT BIDEN SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE KENTANJI BROWN JACKSON
WITH MARATHON QUESTIONS DURING A
CONFIRMATION HEARING.
JUDGE JACKSON PRESSED OVER HER
PHILOSOPHIES, LIBERAL BELIEVES
AND SOFT ON CRIME STANCE.
THE ISSUE AND SENTENCING SHE
HANDED OUT FOR CASES.
>> JUDGES HAVE TO CONSIDER
THINGS LIKE THE VICTIMS.
WHEN I WAS TALKING ABOUT MAKING
SURE THAT VICTIMS, CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE HEARD, IT WAS ABOUT MY
SENTENCING PRACTICES.
>> VICTIMS BEING HURT WITH
RESPECT.
>> Dana: REPUBLICANS PROMISING
TO KEEP THINGS CIVIL BUT THERE
IS A GLARING DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> THERE ARE TWO STANDARDS GOING
ON HERE.
YOU ARE AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
CONSERVATIVE WOMAN, FAIR GAME TO
HAVE YOUR LIFE TURNED
UPSIDE DOWN, TO BE FILIBUSTERED
NO MATTER HOW QUALIFIED YOU ARE.
IF YOU EXPRESS YOUR FAITH AS A
CONSERVATIVE, ALL OF A SUDDEN
YOU ARE A NUT AND WE ARE TIRED
OF IT.
IT IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN, BUT
IT APPALLS ME THAT WE CAN HAVE
SUCH A SYSTEM IN AMERICA.
>> Dana: CLARIFICATION ON THAT
SHE HE WAS TALKING ABOUT IS NOT
BUSH 43 PUT FORWARD AND
2005-2006 SHE WAS FILIBUSTERED
TWO YEARS AS A BLACK
CONSERVATIVE JUDGE AND THERE
WERE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AT
THE TIME AND BIDEN WAS ON THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THAT DID NOT
WANT TO PUT HER FORWARD BECAUSE
ONE OF THE PEOPLE ANONYMOUSLY
SAID IN THE PAPER THEY DID NOT
WANT A REPUBLICAN IN A POSITION
TO NOMINATE A BLACK WOMAN TO THE
SUPREME COURT BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO DO THAT THEMSELVES.
SHE WAS A VERY QUALIFIED JUDGE,
THE SAME THING, IT'S BEEN
22005-2006.
JUDGE SOFT ON CRIME ISSUE OR
JUDICIAL PHILOSOPHY, WHAT DID
YOU TAKE AWAY TODAY?
>> Judge Jeanine: I THINK SHE
HAS NOT INDICATED WHAT JUDICIAL
PHILOSOPHY IS.
SHE TALKED ABOUT HER
METHODOLOGY.
AND SO, HER METHODOLOGY IS AS
USUAL, NUMBER ONE SHE GOES FROM
A POSITION OF IMPARTIALITY AND
THEN HERE'S THE ARGUMENT FROM
BOTH SIDES AND HIS SIDES.
THAT IS WHAT EVERY JUDGE DOES
APPEAR THAT IS NOTHING NEW.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THE THING
THAT BOTHERS ME THOSE THAT DO
DEFEND HER FACE ON SENTENCING OF
THE CONSUMER OF CHILD IS NOT
RECOMMENDING, BY THE WAY MY NO
MANDATORY MINIMUM AND THE
FACT IS THAT SHE TALKS
ABOUT VICTIMS, BUT SHE DOESN'T
REALLY TALK ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THESE YOUNGER CHILDREN ARE
FOREVER IN A POSITION OF LIVING
FOREVER IN IMAGES OF BEING
SEXUALLY MOLESTED ON THE
INTERNET AMONG PORNOGRAPHERS.
AND HER POSITION IS FOR FIRST
TIME THERE SHOULD NOT BE A
MANDATORY.
AND SHE'S GOTTEN AWAY WITH THAT.
I THINK IT IS A LITTLE TOO EASY.
AND I DON'T LIKE THE FACT SHE
SAID, I TALKED TO THE DEFENDANTS
AND TELL THEM ABOUT THE HARM.
TALK ABOUT THE VICTIMS WHO
REALLY SUFFER THE HARM.
SHE CONTINUOUSLY GOES THROUGH
THAT.
WHEN THE TRUTH IS IF YOU CONFESS
CHILD PORNOGRAPHY SHE DOESN'T
WANT TO GIVE TIME BUT IF YOU
RECEIVE AT THE LAW SAYS YOU MUST
GIVE THEM A MINUTE.
I HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING ABOUT
HER SENTENCING AT THE HIGH END.
SO SHE HAS A CLASSIC PUBLIC
DEFENDER.
>> Dana: DID YOU WANT TO
ANSWER THAT, JESSICA?
>> SHE IS A PUBLIC DEFENDER,
THAT WAS HER JOB AND THAT IS HOW
SHE SEES THINGS.
AND I THINK THE ATTEMPT TO